[Music]
take a step back and understand what
you're doing with yourself what makes
you happy are you trying to be rich
because you want to stick it to your
parents or everybody else that said you
couldn't or are you trying to do
something because you actually like it
are you trying to be rich because you
want to go buy [ __ ] to create a
perception that you're happy or do you
actually want to be happy you got your
perspective so listen I think there's
two core things that I want to think
about which is there's a lot of ways I
say it macro micro perspective and
execution when I think about why the
9,000 of you would allocate time and
money to come to an event it means that
there is a need for offense more offense
getting out of defense offense tip to me
this is about one big conversation
one big conversation of what are we
actually doing here and so for me when I
think about what are we actually doing
here the first thing that always comes
to mind and I know some of you have
heard this for me but the fact that the
odds of being a human being are 400
trillion to 1 is something that I
struggle with not thinking about almost
on a daily basis I genuinely believe
that every person in this arena right
now including myself disproportionately
aren't understanding how fortunate we
are to have a life there is literally
nothing there's literally nothing that
you will ever accomplish ever that is
more ridiculous than the fact that you
were even given a life in the first
place the the fact that your mom could
have got up and got another glass of
wine and that would result in you not
being here or a human blows my mind and
so for me one of the things that I
clearly AM is optimistic and positive
but I'm disproportionately practical the
great fortune of my life was that I was
born in the Soviet Union and I came to
America and my parents were poor and we
lived in a studio apartment with
multiple family members and I wasn't
given anything and I genuinely believed
the biggest issue for so many people in
today's world to get to happiness forget
about how you define success from a
money or business standpoint is I just
think most people are entitled I think
that most people are entitled and
genuinely believed that they deserve
something and I think when you come from
zero and you come from such a nasty
place like Soviet Russia the framework
that I was brought up in was lack of
entitlement nobody owes you [ __ ] and if
you want to accomplish something you've
got to do something about it and for me
because let me promise you something
right now
like if you look to the left and right
of you like no matter what your problems
or shortcomings or lack of opportunities
are the person to the left and right of
you has their own life and aren't
worried about your dumb [ __ ] cuz they've
got their own dumb [ __ ] and so for me my
mom basically because my dad worked
every hour so I didn't really even know
him until I started working in the
liquor store as a teenager my mom's lack
of interest in any excuse
created a framework for me so for me
what's interesting about that is that
made me positive not negative what's
amazing about being in a place where you
realize nothing is entitled is you get
into a place of full accountability
genuinely I believe that every problem I
have it I run a thousand person two
hundred million dollar marketing company
vaynermedia and literally every single
problem in that company and let me
promise you there's forty thousand
[ __ ] problems right this second as
I'm on this stage every one of those
problems are my fault because instead of
what I watch so many people do and say
oh [ __ ] Susan's [ __ ] up I realized
that I'm the [ __ ] that hired Susan
my friends I'm coming out the gate here
with a very important framework which is
I promise you that the second that you
stop dwelling stop worrying about [ __ ]
that you cannot control start realizing
that everything [ __ ] up is your fault
you actually get ridiculously happy not
upset I mean it I mean it now just just
to make sure there's no confusion you're
talking to somebody who was a Jewish guy
born in the former Soviet Union where
both my grandfather's went to jail one
for a decade one for two years cuz he
was Jewish so I'm not talking about
there isn't [ __ ] that needs to be
overcome I'm not saying that [ __ ] isn't
[ __ ] up I'm saying that if you cry
about it 24/7 365 nothing's gonna happen
and so in that framework here's my point
if there's any confusion to the
following statement there's a very
significant chance that you won't go to
the place you want to which is this
thing right here should [ __ ] with your
mind like you can't imagine this
computer that I'm holding in my hand is
literally more powerful than the
computer that President Reagan had to
run the free world this computer in my
hand is connected to an Internet that
doesn't know who you are where you came
from or what you're up to the platforms
on it Facebook and Instagram and
LinkedIn and Twitter and podcasting and
YouTube they don't care where you came
from
who your grandpappy was what you did
yesterday
they're unemotional platforms that every
person in this room can go on and start
building something for themselves and
the cost is zero
[Applause]
one of the reasons I'd like to remind
people that the cost is zero is that I
don't know if you know but when
Facebook's reach started to decline or
when Instagram changes its algorithm
people actually complain and are [ __ ]
pissed and I try to remind them that the
platform is free
they're like Facebook's [ __ ] me up
I'm like it's free dick why did the
Instagram I lost followers Instagram
cleaned up their [ __ ] it's free [ __ ]
we on whether you have too much and
there's plenty of people who have too
much and whether you have too little and
everybody in between in 2019 especially
in America we are in full complaint mode
and that is the opportunity if I can do
anything in this room today get one
person of the 9,000 that came in here
dwelling and complaining and thinking
shits [ __ ] up and actually get them to
realize that as one hundred percent the
framework of how they see the world and
literally if they just changed that and
start actually doing if I can accomplish
that waking up at 3:00 [ __ ] 45 in the
morning this morning was worth it and
that is my agenda
because what I'm about to talk about for
the next 25 30 minutes is execution I'm
gonna talk to you about why I think
Instagram ads are so under priced that
whether you're selling real estate or
you're a financial advisor or you want
to sell t-shirts or you want to sell
yogurt where you want to be a comedian a
rapper like it's so under priced
Instagram has the collective attention
of the far majority of our country
Instagram story ads are so under priced
that even if you put content that's
average in it it's over performing this
is exactly what happened on Google in
2001 to 2005 is exactly what happened on
Facebook from 2009 to 2012 when our
collective attention is in one place at
scale and we're actually consuming and
the ads haven't gotten money yet from
BMW and Nike and Pepsi and coca-cola to
make the ad prices go up US
entrepreneurs and individuals have to
strike just like buying beachfront
property in Malibu before people
realized it was Malibu I day trade
attention that's what I do for a living
I spend all my time trying to figure out
where there's attention and then I try
to figure out how to run media ads and
how to create content for those channels
I am agnostic
I do not care about social media I don't
care about Facebook I don't care about
Instagram I don't care about Twitter I
care about your collective attention
whether it's on this stage right now
whether it's the content that I make
whether it's getting ridiculous seats at
WrestleMania so I show up on every
[ __ ] 15 minutes whatever it is I'm
interested in where the attention is and
how do I penetrate it understand what
happens next is the most important part
I've got your attention for these 40
minutes but if this keynote sucks
I lose I've got your attention on
LinkedIn I'm posting on LinkedIn so guys
my last book it's not up here my last
book crushing it I wrote about the most
important platforms in the world to
produce content on I didn't even put
LinkedIn
in it literally only 24 months ago when
I was writing the book I didn't even put
LinkedIn in the book to talk about the
value of LinkedIn for us entrepreneurs
and individuals today as I stand here
right now I would argue that LinkedIn
might be the platform that I'm most
excited for everybody here to go home
and go produce content for and I don't
mean go spam people and send the
messages I mean posting content and it
could be about fitness it can be about
orange juice it could be about anything
LinkedIn today on this day is acting
more like Facebook than four years ago
than Facebook does today the amount of
organic reach you get without paying for
it is so remarkable it's unbelievable
yet we live in a world of headline
readers versus practitioners I produce
content daily I work I just replied to a
comment to somebody that's in the
audience here because they were pumped
not you because it was a lady and your
dude but but you might have been an hour
ago or 30 you were oh you were 20 i DM
do you back i DM do you back but there's
some lady in here like I'm in the
trenches I'm not sitting in an ivory
tower I talk about this content daily
because I do it and I live it you're
talking to somebody I want to remind
everybody everybody starts with zero
followers I want to remind everybody
that everybody starts with zero
followers in 2007 when Twitter hit the
scene I spent six seven eight hours a
day between 7:00 p.m. and 2:00 in the
morning going on Twitter and replying to
every single person that mentioned
anything about wine for six hours a day
for four years and still nobody knew who
the [ __ ] I was so when I hear people put
out three posts on LinkedIn
after a keynote like this and then email
me and say hey Gary Vee loved you in
Chicago
great talk but got to tell you you're
wrong and I reply what happened
well I posted on LinkedIn and nothing
good is happening
and then I asked how long you've been
doing it and like well I've posted twice
for the last two weeks and I reply
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] I just looked
at a student like yeah you know when you
can feel like you like how is anybody
confused that it takes let me say it
very slowly an obnoxious amount of work
to create any level of success there is
so much confusion in the system about
the amount of work ethic that needs to
be ployed to actually have success let
me tell you this anybody you've ever met
that made it worked their [ __ ] face
off you know people that are rich that
didn't they inherited it but they didn't
make it and the confusion of the one or
two stories you hear about when it
happened fast like Instagram or Facebook
has confused everybody and the amount of
excuses we put into the system so that
we don't have to do that work is
remarkable what's interesting is the
reason I have such a good framework on
this is because I am one of the great
all-time worst students in the history
of this country I mean it I literally
never opened a book in high school did
all my scantron test cbcb a CBA if
there's any kids in the crowds I'm gonna
give you a real good secret if you're in
public schools they just push you
through the reason I watch people live
for the weekend and love Friday like
it's the greatest [ __ ] ever because they
hate their Monday through Friday so
[ __ ] much the reason I here
the system's broke my boss is a dick it
doesn't work for me I'm not for that
ollie it's just excuses not to do it's
the same [ __ ] I did from first grade to
twelfth grade because I didn't want to
do that [ __ ] homework that meant
nothing in real [ __ ] life
[Applause]
the problem is that [ __ ] ended when I
was 18 you've got the rest of your life
which gets me back to this this thing
freaks me out so much you can't imagine
because the one thing this thing is is
actual opportunity that our grandparents
didn't grow up with this thing allows
you to still be practical and maintain
the job that you hate so you can pay off
your student loans and your mortgage but
create your side hustle on here around
the [ __ ] that you actually love where
that's the [ __ ] Chicago Bears weather
that's [ __ ] sneakers whether that's
doing comedy skits whether that's
reincarnating the formula that your
grandmother had for soup from your
country that you're now gonna sell
direct to consumer on the back of every
eats I don't give a [ __ ] what ridiculous
thing comes out of your mouth this thing
if you make content on it and understand
where people actually pay attention
actually gives you a prayer for that to
happen as long as you do a couple of
core things and that's what I'm going to
talk about core thing number one the
single biggest thing in my opinion that
the majority of these people in this
room are doing wrong this is number one
I believe that 98% of the people in this
arena right now by too much dumb [ __ ] I
have become crazy fascinated as I've
lived my life of trying to understand
why the [ __ ] so many of my parents
immigrants friends other immigrants and
just immigrants in general have a
disproportionate success rate in the
framework of America and I finally
figured it out they're not smarter it's
not even necessarily that they work
harder it's that they come to America
and they buy nothing stupid for 15
[ __ ] years they just live like [ __ ]
buy nothing save money buy a business
and move on the level of insecurity that
is permeating this country so that
people end up buying cars and how
and clothes that they can't afford to
impress people that they don't even like
is the great epidemic in our society I
get to say this from truth I lived my
20s all my 20s 22 to 29 my twenties in a
shitty [ __ ] apartment in Springfield
New Jersey I didn't buy any [ __ ]
clothes I didn't have swag [ __ ]
sneakers I didn't come on no [ __ ]
vacations
I just [ __ ] worked and saved money
and I was building a business for my
parents not even for myself so when I
tell people to be patient it's easy cuz
I lived it I don't stand up here ever
talking about [ __ ] that I didn't
actually do first and so if you're not
pumped if you're not like loving life
before you try to figure out the hook or
the secret or if you think Tony's gonna
read [ __ ] your [ __ ] brain or I'm
gonna give you or I'm gonna give you
some [ __ ] secret to do on [ __ ]
Instagram that's gonna change everything
before you think about that go home and
look at your [ __ ] credit card bill and
stop buying dumb [ __ ]
because when you don't buy gum [ __ ] that
money stays in the [ __ ] bank and you
can do something with your [ __ ] life
instead of having a new pair of [ __ ]
off whites who the [ __ ] you flossing for
[ __ ]
[ __ ] Chicago yep you think somebody's
gonna like you better cuz your [ __ ]
got a new Audi you dick
Jesus and that is what is most
interesting about this place because if
you want to look at this place in a
negative way it's super easy cuz
everybody's [ __ ] faked lifing on
Instagram you mean people here are gonna
go hiking this weekend for the [ __ ]
stupid picture they don't want to go
hiking they just want to get a couple
more likes on Instagram
I got [ __ ] I know people who jump the
fence at night at private plane imports
to take a photo to make pretend they fly
private do you [ __ ] understand what's
going on and then it gets deeper there
are people in [ __ ] relationships
right now posting photos of themselves
on vacation acting like they're [ __ ]
happy my friends this is a manifesto in
Chicago this morning about executing on
truths that [ __ ]
and let me give you very basic truths if
you spend money on [ __ ] you don't need
you're gonna lose if you buy those
things to impress other people you've
already lost you need to take a step
back and understand what are you're
doing this is not a conversation today
about making more money success means
being happy not how much money you have
we are in the middle stages of mental
unhappiness mental issues in our country
predicated on a lot of different things
not paying the piper in 2009 like we
should have we should just be getting
out of a depression but we all got
bailed out let's start there on the
greatest generation of funny parenting
I've ever seen in my life
my favorite thing going on in the world
right now is 40 to 60 year olds [ __ ]
on millennials when they were the
[ __ ] that raised those people that's
my favorite [ __ ] these kids are so soft
no [ __ ] dick you gave them an eighth
place trophy
[Applause]
these kids don't take feedback well no
[ __ ] dick when their teacher yelled at
them you ran to the school and [ __ ]
fought like an [ __ ] [ __ ] that pisses
me off guys let kids lose let's let's
actually talk about losing micro losing
is the greatest [ __ ] I stand here in
front of you today because the first 18
years of my life the world told me I
sucked and I lost that everything I
sucked at school I wasn't big enough for
sports everything [ __ ] sucked
that's right bro but we're [ __ ] here
now and we're here now because a
singular person in my life my mother
instilled such disproportionate self
esteem in me without creating
entitlement when I was nice to people
she [ __ ] praised the [ __ ] out of it
when I struck out in a game she didn't
make pretend some [ __ ] was rigged she
said the picture was better than you
dick the fine line how many people here
consume my content I'm gonna give you a
secret I've never said all I am is the
puppet and the byproduct of tomorrow
Vaynerchuk what I'm trying to do for you
is what she did for me what tomorrow my
mom Vaynerchuk that's why I said did for
me was she positively and optimistically
gave me a framework of the world but she
didn't create entitlement because when I
lost I lost and when I won I won and so
when you look at my content you can see
certain times when it feels [ __ ] a
little rough and a little edgy and other
times when it's warm and fuzzy it's
because both exist and everybody thinks
you have to pick sides it's like the
[ __ ] in our country right now people
think you have to pick sides
it [ __ ] makes no sense the reality is
this just like in our country we're just
one human life is binary in that some
things are soft and
things are hard and the reality is some
things are very basic and here they are
I believe the following that we are so
blessed to be in this room because for
the first time in my life I think it's
practical not ideological to actually
build a business around the things you
actually like to do which will then mean
that you'll actually work the 13 hours a
day if you want to make a million
dollars a year that it requires because
there is no [ __ ] passive income do
you understand you can make a good
investment
I understand but when you buy 30 homes
properly and you think it's passive what
about when the tornado comes what about
when the [ __ ] person that manages it
quits what about when somebody lights
the [ __ ] house on fire the amount of
money you make is wildly correlated to
the amount of anxiety and stress you're
able to carry people want it easy out
here there is no easy if you want to
live a 1% life people are so funny in
the audacity of the words that come out
of their mouth my friends the top 1%
earners in America one of the richest
countries in the world start at four
hundred twenty thousand dollars a year
if you are in this room and you make
four hundred twenty thousand dollars a
year that means you make in the top one
percent in this country yet everybody's
walking around like if you don't make a
milly you haven't even started
we're delusional and all the people that
make 420 and above they work their big
off guys they work well like it's so
much work it takes work now what I
believe is what what absolutely just
drives me so happy and why I want to be
here is I can't believe that you can
actually make funny videos on Instagram
and get brands to pay you $10,000 for
you to hold a bottle of Pepsi in your
hand I mean it's it's crazy what's crazy
is you can literally go start a Shopify
store and sell t-shirts or makeup or
bowties because your grandfather wore
bowties and you design it on the
internet and it gets shipped to you from
China and then you
Instagram adds the level of price if
this existed when I was a kid
[ __ ] college I wouldn't have graduated
high school I'm not sure I would have
made it through [ __ ] middle school
this is a mindset an execution game you
have to understand how ridiculously good
it is and I believe that's very hard
when there's so much negativity being
pushed on social media on mainstream
media everybody's trying to convince you
it's bad it's the greatest it's the
greatest the problem is everybody can do
it and supply and demand then kicks in
everybody can sell bow ties everybody
can make funny videos
everybody can show off their abs and get
the right angle on their [ __ ] ass and
all that [ __ ] everybody can do that but
it doesn't mean that you shouldn't try
and more importantly and what I really
want to leave you with is something you
really need to understand which is
almost everybody fails because of their
intentions almost everybody fails
because of their intentions they start
businesses for themselves make sense
we're humans but everything that runs
through their mind is what's in it for
me how do I maximize my profit what's it
gonna be like for me how is it gonna be
good for me the only way to succeed in
the world we live in is to actually be
consumer centric there's a very specific
reason that Amazon is winning it's
because everything that happens at that
company is trying to figure out how it's
good for you it's good for you to buy
prime because you love the fact that all
year that means everything you buy has
free shipping that's good for you it
comes quick coz that's good for you
because you value time the singular
reason that my content has worked
whether it was wine for the first six
years of my career or it's been business
over the last eight years has worked is
because before I post any piece of
content in my mind I think about how is
this gonna be valuable to you how is
this singular piece of content going to
bring any value to you the single reason
I've been able to build an audience is I
don't put out content that's a top of
the funnel piece of content that gets
you into my database so I
can sell you my product it's a piece of
content that I hope brings you value
which then creates a relationship with
us the end period the end and so if
you're taking anything from this talk
number one the opportunity is ridiculous
I need you to understand that if you
don't know what Shopify is google it and
learn about the platform that costs
nothing to start a store on the internet
that works really well and sell
something on it if you don't know how to
write an run an Instagram story ad like
I referenced it earlier you wrote a note
about it but I didn't get to the detail
the reason I didn't get to the detail is
because the details are called
google.com go to [ __ ] google.com type
in how do I run an Instagram ad enter
and eight thousand trillion [ __ ]
billion results come back
everybody wants people to come up here
and [ __ ] draw [ __ ] on a [ __ ] white
paper are you out of your [ __ ] mind
it's 2019 information is a commodity
information is zero it doesn't cost
anything don't buy information the
Internet it's free take a step back and
understand what you're doing with
yourself what makes you happy are you
trying to be rich because you want to
stick it to your parents or everybody
else that said you couldn't or are you
trying to do something because you
actually like it are you trying to be
rich because you want to go buy [ __ ] to
create a perception that you're happy or
do you actually want to be happy we live
in remarkable times the Internet is the
single greatest and most complex and
ridiculous invention in the history of
the human being we luckily for some
unknown reason happen to be living
during the era of it finally hitting its
scale 30 years in and it is in its prime
opportunity the comp I would make is
imagine we were living in Chicago
hundreds and hundreds of years ago and
we could be buying up property for
almost nothing because we just didn't
understand what was actually happening
that's how I think about attention on
today it is so valuable and it is so
under priced and literally the only
thing that's stopping you is insecurity
the reason you're not posting is you're
worried that nobody's gonna care what
you have to say the reason you're not
posting is you don't like the way you
look in the picture or the camera all
these different things that come down to
what other people think not what you
think about yourself the reason my man
over there I was clapping and I love
talking about losing for the first 18
years of my life is because it was easy
as [ __ ] because I didn't give a [ __ ]
what you had to say I was in my own
cocoon doing my own thing making my own
self happy and I stand here today in the
same goddamn place do I want my content
to do well sure do I want my businesses
to be successful yep do I want empathy
wine to do well sure and the sneaker do
I want of course that's like I'm playing
I'm playing my game I want to win I'm
playing my game but when I lose I'm
grateful for the opportunity to play
[Applause]
what I learned about myself at a young
age was that I see it I gotta leave with
this though I recently realized oh [ __ ]
this is all working because when I was 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 when it was a summer
day in the 80s in Jersey and everybody
went out to play play hoop whatever like
I wanted to work
I rang doorbells and washed people's
cars
I sold lemonade baseball cars exploded
and I started buying them and flipping
them then I turned 14 and wanted to work
at my dad's liquor store for 14 hours a
day for two bucks an hour because I
realized work was my passion I liked the
game it's why athletes being in this
Stadium athletes that loved their game a
lot of athletes don't as I've gotten to
know athletes they do it cuz that's
where the money is but they're not happy
they don't love it it blows a lot of our
minds because we'd love to play in the
[ __ ] league but not everybody wants
that this is one big game of happiness
and the Internet allows you to but are
you patient enough and are you secure
and have enough self-esteem to go
through the process of eating the
[ __ ] dirt to get to a place of
happiness success my friends needs to
stop being talked about how much money
you have it needs to be talked about how
many [ __ ] smiles you put on your face
it does it does and I love the cliche
[ __ ] [ __ ] I know you're in the
crowd right now they're like easy for
you dick
you have money [ __ ] I was happy
before I had it you need no weep dick
you didn't know me you didn't know me
and I don't necessarily know you but I
know this because I read 10,000 [ __ ]
comments a day in my DM we have a
ridiculous opportunity you just need to
see it please try to build a business
around the thing that you would do if
you weren't getting paid for it because
it's the only thing that you're gonna
work hard enough at because you actually
like it go flip Thomas the trains on
eBay start a blog about [ __ ] Smurfs
start a podcast about reviewing whiskies
or the 85 Bears my man
you could start a podcast at an
Instagram account and a YouTube show
about just the 85 Bears and get $100,000
in sponsorship from car dealerships and
pizza shops and all sorts of [ __ ] in
this town and to me the fact that that's
true and so many of those same people
are making 87,000 being a lawyer 90,000
be an executive and hating life or let
me just play with this and I'm gonna
leave with this would you really rather
make two hundred twelve thousand a year
and be unhappy or live or make ninety
seven thousand and do the thing that you
love the most and the only thing you
have to do is live a little more humbly
just a little we have to [ __ ] talk
about this that's the game that's the
game please wake up
I love you Chicago wake up sir cog Oh
I see you back there I see them up there